over the past 50 plus years charles koch
grew his family business coke industries
into one of the largest privately held
companies in america
while playing a leading role in creating
or supporting the modern libertarian
movement
and some of its major institutions among
them the cato
institute the institute for humane
studies mercatus center
and the charles koch foundation a
non-profit that supports many
organizations including reason
foundation
the publisher of reason magazine along
with his brother david who passed away
last year at the age of 79 the 85 year
old billionaire became not only one of
the most successful businessmen in the
country
but among the most controversial with
leftists blaming the koch brothers
for many of our contemporary problems
coke has just published believe in
people a book that seeks to offer a
paradigm shift that calls for
all of us to move away from the top down
approach to solving the really big
problems by instead empowering people
from the bottom up to act on their
unique gifts
and contribute to the lives of others in
a conversation with coke and his
co-author brian hooks who is chairman
and ceo of stand together
and the president of the charles koch
foundation i discussed the 2020 election
the successes and failures of the
libertarian movement and what they see
as the defining challenges
and opportunities in the coming decade
charles koch brian hooks thanks for
talking to reason thanks for having us
thanks nick good to see you again it's
been a few years it has indeed
um so as a starting point charles could
you
kind of give what's the controlling idea
of believe in people
it's the idea that that transformed my
life
and and that of so many others and
enabled me
to accomplish more than
i ever dreamed and so so my
goal with the book is to is
is to use it to help
many more people benefit from these
ideas and these
are the principles of human progress
which
in large part have to do with bottom-up
empowering of people and
when that happens and people are
empowered
many of them become social entrepreneurs
and when there are enough of these
social entrepreneurs as we've through
seen throughout history they transform
society
and move it it's never been perfect and
never will be perfect because human
beings aren't perfect
toward directionally toward a society
morally more of equal rights and mutual
benefit
where people succeed by assisting one
another
and everyone has the opportunity to
realize their potential so that's
that's what this this book is about and
and it tells the story my story
which is probably the least interesting
but the story of people through history
who have changed society transformed
themselves
transformed society by being social
entrepreneurs
and then talks about the work we're
doing today
and all the social the thousands of
social entrepreneurs
we're helping to empower others
to change their lives and help everybody
rise
right and a lot of these issues have to
do with things like education
uh substance abuse housing whatever
brian who
who's a an exemplary social entrepreneur
um and can you explain in the book and
can you explain how that fits together
with the larger groups stand together
yeah absolutely so you know as as
charles said
we we tell a lot of different stories
about people and social entrepreneurs
that we think exemplify this model of
bottom-up solutions
you know the the three big ideas in the
book that while there's going to be a
ton of different
solutions to all of the different
challenges that come at our country
with all have in common is this this
core belief in people
that it's it makes more sense to empower
people from the bottom up
invest in those that are closest to the
problems as the source of the solutions
and then unite with anybody to do right
you look at a
organization that we feature in the
preface and a group that we've worked
with that stand together for
i guess the better part of four years
now a group called the family
independence initiative
i think they exemplify each one of those
those big ideas
family independence initiative was
founded by a guy named mauricio miller
run by a guy named jesus harena the
thing that both jesus and mariso have in
common
is that they experienced poverty first
hand
growing up and so they've got the kind
of personal knowledge
that tends to be key to unlocking really
effective solutions to
problems whatever we're talking about
and the the as as charles has
would say the the proof of the pudding
is in the eating the uh
the results that the family independence
initiatives gets
in terms of empowering families who are
in poverty to
emerge from poverty from rise out to to
rise out of poverty
are off the charts especially when you
compare them
to some of the top-down alternatives
that
do they can explain a little bit of what
they actually do
yeah i mean it's a great model so you
know whereas the top-down approach looks
at people in
poverty as a problem to be solved and it
brings people
from the outside in to try to kind of
tell them what to do
family independence initiative takes the
opposite approach they
bring families who are in similar
situations in poverty
together under the idea that the
solution to those families poverty
exists within the families
but just like all of us they need some
help in order to really emerge
they need capital social capital and
financial capital
and through through some some pretty
simple tools
the family independence initiative helps
those families to express
their goals and then to work together to
help each other achieve those goals
and this very top-villain notion of
mutual assistance
but 27 of the families that participate
in these programs after two years
rise out of poverty and stay out of
poverty which is extraordinary again
relative to the to the alternative
they double their savings uh and and and
again
this is uh sort of based on this deep
belief in people right we believe in
those families
and then we recognize that you know that
many of us including jesus and
and mauricio and the team there they've
got some
some skills and some things that can
help those families to achieve
more than they otherwise could and the
and the starting point to as we've found
learned the hard way is it to believe in
people
is to recognize that everyone has a gift
that everyone has something to offer and
we learned that from
multiple intelligence theory from
ricardo's
law of comparative advantage the
division of labor by comparative
advantage
which is what raised humanity out of
eternal dire poverty the
the the that people started to
be empowered to to to try things
to do things and focus on what they were
good at
recognize what they were good at and
what they were not in focus
and then exchange with others and then
this brought about this whole
change in the culture from everybody
in conflict with other with each other
to
to cooperating to supporting each other
to assisting each other by trading
each concentrating on what they do best
and and and
and and exchanging and this also happens
to
follow the second law of thermodynamics
which you you
you you know very well is that
i live the second law of thermodynamics
yeah i've been tending towards entropy
since i was born yeah that's that that
use
entropy uselessness uh
and uh and waste increases
in a closed system so we all need to be
open and what does that mean it means
open to
to different ideas different people
different things different approaches
and so try to find common ground with
others
charles can you you know one of the
things that i think uh people reading
the book will be
uh interested to understand is uh you're
the kind of the two two of the major
figures
uh who's thought you're following
there's friedrich hayek on the one hand
that's not going to be surprising to
anybody who knows
free market economics and why not but
also abraham maslow
can you talk about how these two guys
kind of fit together
for you and and how that that energizes
a lot of what you're doing
when when i think of of them in in
in harmony i think of uh of uh
hayek's uh statement of what
probably the greatest discovery in the
history of mankind was
and that is that people can live
together
in peace and to their mutual advantage
without having to agree on common aims
by only being bound
by abstract rules of conduct
now what does that say that says bottom
up
is what works and that's what maslow
said he said what you can be you must be
if you don't if you don't develop your
capabilities
and realize your potential you may be
successful
externally but you will be deeply
unhappy
because you're not fulfilling your gifts
your nature
and so that's bob the way that's done is
bottom up
each person discovering their gift
turning it into valued skills and then
using it to succeed by contributing
so they're both coming from it and this
is what i find and with the second law
of thermodynamics
they all fit and this is what when i
started studying this
the these i became fascinated and
transformed my life
studying these principles of human
progress
the ones i i really gravitated those
with it was from all the different
disciplines and perspectives
they came together they reinforced each
other
and and those are the ones that worked
in history
that lifted societies up and headed them
toward more
toward the ability to enable more people
to realize their potential
and contribute and work in harmony and
peace
so nick the real opportunity that we see
and it stand together is how do you
translate those big insights
into actual action that can empower
people to overcome the challenges
so we talked about the family
independence initiative as an example of
a program that does that
but but no program can can do it all on
its own right there's no single solution
to
the big problems that we're trying to
solve and so what we put forward in the
book is that what's necessary is this
comprehensive approach
so you take what charles just said
seriously how do we really help to
put society in a position where they're
empowering people to discover their own
paths
in a way that satisfies themselves finds
fulfillment
by helping others and so programs like
family independence initiative are
important
because communities play a critical role
in empowering people
but we know public policy does as well
right and so you've got to identify
those barriers and policies
say that are that are perpetuating
poverty things like occupational
licensure that sort of thing
but but for a long time we've kind of
left a lot of the other
opportunities in society off the table
uh business is that
is that coming out of uh from a kind of
rigid libertarian idea
that you know the government shouldn't
be involved in it so we're not really
going to talk about it
no no the the government has a role
but it's i mean government is one of
what we look at
as four uh uh types
of institutions one are community
institutions educational institutions
business institutions and
institutions and what our goal is is to
help
each one move toward doing the things
that empower people to improve their
lives
and the lives of others and move toward
this society of equal rights and mutual
benefit
so the policies so we we we
we work with thousands of social
entrepreneurs
across all four of these sets of
institutions
and and what we do is support those
who are going in that direction and we
don't ask for
for perfection if we find they agree
with us on one
they may disagree with us on all the
others but we will work with them on
that one
and that's the only way we found we can
get we can move society forward in that
yeah at uh various points in the book
frederick douglass the uh 19th century
abolitionist the orator
uh comes up a lot uh particularly in
this concept of uniting with
anybody to do good brian you know uh
frederick douglass social entrepreneur i
mean it's kind of one way of talking
about him but why
how does he inhabit or personify well
let me
may i take that because sure i'm the i'm
the
as you say as you saw in the book i have
uh
my two uh i i
list three categories of people that
have influenced me and that my
my two heroes are frederick douglass and
victor frankel
and and frederick douglass particularly
because of what he
overcame to him to be empowered
what he did with it to not be vengeful
or hateful
but to help everybody to eliminate all
kinds of
injustices and then he wrote about the
aha moments
the very things we've been talking about
for example he
he he found
or he realized that he wasn't enslaved
because he was inferior but because he
was
being kept ignorant so he taught himself
to read when he was eight
then at age 16 he he had the opportunity
to teach sunday school
so he taught them to read and here's
what his comment was
at last i found a way to contribute
so he was contribution motivated even
as enslaved and then he he escaped
and he got a job and he says
i'm not only a free man i'm a free
working man
and then he went to these abolitionist
rallies
and finally they called on him but one
all the top
abolitionists were speaking garrison and
and the rest
and and he was the best so he found his
gift
and he dedicated his life to that and
became very successful
and then a powerful one of the top
social entrepreneurs in our history and
uh uh brian i will point out that uh
it was the irish who beat up frederick
douglass when he
was free in the north i'll take that as
i'll take it as a personal
dig based on our history together our
common uh our common uh
yes i i think it's important though to
to note i mean we learn
so much from guys like douglas and other
these just unbelievable social
entrepreneurs who overcame
you know unimaginable barriers but i
think we make a mistake if we say
well they can do it and therefore you
know i can't or other people can't so
what we try to do
in the book is also share stories of
modern day people
who exemplify the same sort of path
that douglas recognizing that that
nobody today struggles with what what he
had to
right uh what's who's who's a a good
short example of that
we look at a guy like anton lucky for
instance right who's just this
phenomenal guy we met four or five years
ago part of a group called urban
specialists anton
early on about 14 years old started the
most violent gang
in dallas the the bloods went on to
you know as one does after you started
gang when you're 14 spend time in prison
but anton in prison begins this personal
transformation which
follows remarkably the path that charles
just described for douglas
and long story short he comes out of
prison having discovered
his leadership gifts and is now applying
them
to help other kids go down a better path
than he did
and and you say well geez that's great
maybe anton can help thousands of kids
during his lifetime which which he will
but it's more than that
by pointing out what anton is able to
accomplish
right somebody who most of the the rest
of the country or society wouldn't
really believe in
right when we believe in a guy like
anton and we tell his story and we
celebrate what he's done
he inspires thousands of others to look
within themselves to figure out how they
can contribute can we uh talk you know
at some point so right now we're kind of
talking about um
community efforts to help you know
people at a very um
kind of fundamental level family unit
gangs things like that
even educational institutions at one
point in the book you write
america needs a better business culture
and it's you know it's clear that
a lot of people certainly you guys do i
do you know we express ourselves we
express our core values our desires our
aspirations through the work that we do
um coke industries makes a lot a lot of
money
because it's doing so you know it's
making things that people want at a
price that they'll they're willing to
pay
talk about the two things i guess um
charles at one point you write that when
you took over koch industries after your
father died in the late 60s
you had to change the company's culture
to one of empowerment
not control can you explain a little bit
what what that meant
right well it was it was uh before my
father
talked me into joining the company by
telling me
he was he was very ill and so he wasn't
able to really run the company and so it
wasn't doing that well
and and he didn't have long to live so
either i come back to run it
or or he would have to sell it
and and i and he said you already own a
piece of the company so i was looking
for entrepreneurial opportunity and i
didn't think i'd get a better offer than
that one
so i and he was true to his word i mean
he had been growing up he had been tough
on me he had me work it
at tough jobs from the time i was six
all my free time because he didn't want
me to be a country club bomb
but i was reluctant to come back because
i didn't need more tough stuff i wanted
to be independent but
but he gave me that offer and he was
true to his word
so so he said i could run it any way i
wanted
except i needed his approval to sell it
and and so first thing i saw
is there was a protectionist mentality
in the company and that is
we're not going to do new things we're
not going to take risks we're just going
to
do the status quo and i'm coming and i'm
a kid i
know i want to do new things i want to
blow it up
and and and so i as i was learning
these principles of human progress
i i created this model
of of of of succeeding by
creating virtuous cycles of mutual
benefit
in the company and what what that means
is you
figure out what capabilities you have
that will create value
for others starting with customers but
also your employees your suppliers
uh your communities and society as a
whole
and and so so that's what so we changed
the whole
and then you continually transform
yourself to do
more and more to build additional
capabilities and this leads to new
opportunities and the new opportunities
lead
to the need to create new capabilities
and so on
in never-ending cycles of
improvement and progress and that's what
we started doing and this stuff worked
that's why i say it transformed my life
i didn't think i was
that capable and i wasn't the ideas were
and so so so we focused on creating
value for others
and empowering our employees from the
bottom up
yeah what what does that mean because
you know one of the things i've read
all of your books over the years and
i've heard a lot about market-based
management and i intellectually i
understand the idea and it sounds great
but then as a former manager myself i'm
i
i don't know how to implement it what
does it mean to kind of set your
employees
free to well figure out what to do every
the first job of every supervisor
is to enable their reports
their employees to self-actualize
and what that means is they work with
employees
to find what gifts they have what
they'll be passionate about
and then rather than stick them in a
roll most of which they aren't good at
design the roles to fit the capabilities
of the employees
and then give them the tools and with
the technology today
we've for example we've invested in
nearly 30 billion
in technology within the last decade
and we use this technology not to
control
our employees but to empower them
and and give them the tools and the
knowledge
and and the authority to make more
decisions and we
are getting innovations improvements
from from all levels through their and
that passion
has gone up so so when i look at society
and what could be done
and how you change the culture
i mean i look at and what how this is
working here
so this isn't just a theory this is
something i see every day
and just to say what the stakes are nick
i mean 70
of people almost 70 of people report
that they are completely disengaged from
their job
they don't find any fulfillment in their
job so you think about the human
potential that's just being lost
by the way business typically runs if
you can change that and you do things
like what charles just talked about
focus on self-actualization in the
workplace i mean not only are you going
to get personal
value out of it but think about the
productivity you can unleash
you know uh charles in the book you say
that you you know your
your basic dynamic is trial and error
and you emphasize that you made a lot of
errors during uh your career what what's
one of the biggest kind of signature
mistakes that you made
as the head of koch industries well i
look at it
as i i'm i'm i follow the stoic
philosophy that is
uh grateful for everything and entitled
to nothing
and i and this is uh consistent with
thomas edison's philosophy remember when
he
he had uh all these he tried all these
things to make a new battery for nine
thousand things that didn't work
and his friends said well god i'm sorry
you had all this failure she said i
haven't had any failures i've found nine
thousand things that don't work
and i look at at our failures
and that's what's made us successful so
and if you don't if you're not the only
way you can
never make a mistake or never have a
failure
if you don't try anything new and guess
what that means
you have total failure because you're
going out of business
given the the process of creative
destruction that's going on
at at uh light speed pace today
so we're ramping it up so we're we're
driving more creative destruction and
what we
tell every employee whatever you're
doing
that you may be best at the world at
what you're doing our business may be
the leader and all that it's not good
enough
if we don't improve faster than others
we're going out of business and get
everybody think so everybody comes to
work how
how do i how do i drive
innovation and find new and better ways
to create more value for our customers
and our other constituencies
one of the uh more interesting sections
of the book i think
is when you're talking about kind of
building a business a better business
culture
you guys really go after corporate
welfare you talk about a corporate
welfare crisis
um and i would like you to talk a little
bit about
coke industries was a major producer of
ethanol and yet you lobbied to end
direct subsidies of ethanol how did you
sell that to
your investors how did you sell that to
your employees
because that seems to be you know you
know that sounds like it would be kind
of a tough sell
because our because this is what we
don't
i mean we train uh everybody
educate all our employees in our
philosophy
and and a good part of their rewards are
they helping us build this culture
of creating value for others and it
when when when people
focus in their career on creating value
for others
rather than gaming the system and and
trying to be succeed by tricks or
playing politics or whatever
it transforms them it changes their
habits i can't tell you how many
employees
have retired uh or left the company
who either come in to see me or write me
and tell me that this
transformed their life now
now it's not and not only in business
but in
the in working with their their children
with their families
uh in their philanthropy even some say
this i i've i've worked with my my
my church or my synagogue to help them
be more effective in helping their
prisoners
so this this stuff is so powerful you
can see at 85 people ask me why you
why you work so hard now because i'm
i mean what am i going to do i love
doing this
and when i see that it really helps
people it empowers them
man that's what makes my day so a big
uh error that you kind of confess to or
discuss in the book
is uh having spent a lot of time trying
to elect
mostly republicans uh in in political
battles you had you know
infamous notorious coveted
uh seminars a couple times a year is for
many years where you raise money for
particular uh uh politicians and you've
said
uh you know the wall street journal
quoted you this is in the book
boy did we screw up what a mess talking
about partisanship
um how did you how did you come to the
understanding that trying to uh kind of
work the political system
in that way was was not working well i i
i
always had that that view i
well i've been at this for nearly 60
years and
for the the first 50
i wasn't in politics at all because
politics as you as you see
everything we we try to do is based on
mutual benefit
and politics can't do that because it
isn't win-win
it's win lose you're running against
somebody
and either you win it's not going to be
mutual benefit
so and and that's and then then i've
taken to heart
what george washington's insight and his
farewell
address beware of political parties
because they'll tell you they're there
where
to help you and they're really there to
gain and keep power
so we stayed out of politics and that
but then
we got it why did you get into politics
well that's what that's what it seemed
like you were you were kind of
on the right path what drew you in but
okay so we we started getting
into policies okay because we realize we
can't just do it with education
and empowering people we've got to have
policies that allow
this if we have too many policies that
are holding people back that aren't
based on equal rights and mutual benefit
that aren't they're keeping people from
realizing their potential so we needed
to change those policies and then as we
got into that
okay it's hard to find politicians that
will really
work to empower people or have policies
so
we need to help elect some and then
brian can can tell how we how we got
it because i i i i don't say the right
things when i get into
well you know this is a libertarian
podcast so you can curse
that's right that's right if you're
going
there's a there's a pretty big
misunderstanding i think about uh
even the extent to involvement in
politics back in
the middle 2010s right which is really
when when this experiment was going on
right
and even after the financial crisis was
kind of the
between say 2000 analysis 9 2010 and
2014 was this experiment with hey if we
want to
find politicians that are going to be
truer to the principles of empowerment
let's get engaged in politics right and
figure out if we can do it
we we played the game like like
everybody does we picked a team
in case it was the republicans not
because we were republicans or because
we had any love for the party
necessarily
but because we thought that was going to
be the most productive way to find
people that would pass
policies to empower people three cycles
later
experiment run recognize hey this isn't
working
the way that it ought to so let's do
something different
but even at that heyday of our
involvement in the political process
that was never more than 10 of
everything
that this philanthropic community was
doing and it's never exceeded that today
it's less than that
but we're still engaged in politics
we're just doing it differently
yeah well let me just point out that
politicians like uh
women of easy virtue come pretty cheaply
so you don't have to spend that much
right you're not going to get us to
curse nick you're not going to get us
the curse but um so yeah you
you talk in the book about um you know
that you picked a partisanship or
uh you partisanship over kind of policy
um and then you're talking about part
partnership over partisanship
so well we never we never picked
partnership partisanship over policy we
thought
for a while partisanship would be the
path towards better policy
but again you know you live and learn
and what what do you think we did what
went wrong with the republican party
well
it's just well i don't think so it's
it's what george washington said
what i mean what is the what is the
politician's
uh profit and loss it's where they get
reelected
that's profit and if they lose they had
a big loss
so so they're going to do whatever will
get re-elected so we had all these
we supported these politicians who
uh who said they were for
all this stuff we
we vetted them on that and they were
saying all the right things and then i'd
be watching tv
and they would be coming up for the
opposite i you know i got to tell you uh
charles it's hard to take you seriously
now if you're only now or only a few
years ago was realizing that politicians
lie
when there were no collapse well i i
told you i stayed out of it for 50 years
but i got
sucked into it anyway so i said to brian
i said i said brian we've got to change
who who were the big disappointments
could i you know i i
i hate to use a trope from the left but
name some names who were the biggest
disappointments that you
you guys kind of backed you said like
these are good bets to pursue
limited effective government strategies
and then they just
didn't deliver i think what we're more
interested in talking about is what does
it look like going forward right and
this is what we talked about in the book
is look what you learn from that
experience is not that politicians lie
of course we we knew that
right but what you learn is that the
party system is structured not to
produce good policy but to produce
perpetual party
and so how do you disrupt that how do
you change those dynamics because look
even when you talk to the folks in in
congress right
people are frustrated you know a lot of
those folks didn't come here to do
what's going on right now but they don't
see it pointing out however unpopular
donald trump has been
during his presidency uh congress is
like half as popular
so yeah that's right yeah that's right
they have their own problems to deal
with
but but policy coalitions can be formed
not through
this notion of sort of bipartisanship
which which doesn't tend to lead to much
profound outcome
but through a real nonpartisan approach
right the idea that we'll work with
anybody to do right regardless of party
in the context of because you guys were
heavily involved in this with criminal
justice reform
right and the first step that and that
seems to be a place where
an unlikely coalition of people who
didn't have a lot in common except for
those
issues in the criminal justice bucket
came together
um and you know it actually got
something done and we see that as a
model you know so you look at criminal
justice reform what happened is exactly
as you said
we looked for common ground rather than
focusing on the things that separated us
with the groups that we worked with
put together a coalition of well over 30
groups right everybody from the aclu to
the american conservative union
the national organization of black law
enforcement officers i mean you name it
it was a
who's who of of a coalition real diverse
and what that did was it said to
politicians hey
in the past you know for 25 years i mean
you know this reason's worked on this as
well as anybody has
criminal justice reform was off limits
because you'd get willie horton
right if you were a republican or a
democrat if you dared to speak the truth
about the criminal justice system
you risked your opponent basically
pointing to the one person that
that did harm and and that would come
back to uh to
to get you out of office so all these
diverse groups came back and said i
don't care if you're a democrat or
republican do the right thing we got
your back
and because of the diversity of that
coalition that it was robust and it was
it allowed both parties to do the right
thing that's a model that we think we
can apply to a lot of different issues
yeah what are what are some of those
other issues that you're particularly
interested on
uh interested in i mean the one that is
ready to go right now and we're very
hopeful going forward is immigration
in what way uh i mean we have uh you
know one of the
weird uh and maybe obviously uh
you know uh it was gonna turn out this
way but uh under donald trump who
was elected being very anti-immigrant uh
pro-immigrants that
uh sentiment in america is at historic
highs that's right
um but it's also true that george bush
who won re-election in 2004 made
comprehensive immigration reform and you
know it was kind of good
good reform it was more friendly to
immigrants didn't get a past uh
obama didn't get a pass so how how are
you going to affect
change in immigration we think the
change maker here is what we just talked
about
in all of those past cases you pursue a
partisan strategy right
that's the way the policy making has
always been done in dc
but if we can bring the kind of diverse
coalition that we brought to criminal
justice reform
to an issue like improving our
immigration system
you change the dynamic right we also see
it for instance on foreign policy
you know stopping the crazy adventurism
that is so counterproductive you know
foreign wars that have nothing to do
with national security
here again you've got a dynamic at 70
percent of the country thinks we ought
to be out of afghanistan
why aren't we right because neither
party wants to give the other a win
but if you can bring that diverse
coalition to that you can make
really important changes that that help
people's lives that help the national
security and help our fiscal situation
by the way
right can i ask uh related to this where
uh where is koch industries or where is
the
uh charles koch foundation on an issue
like climate change
which seems to be it has become a
background issue where everybody is
everybody basically acknowledges that
climate change is happening that human
activity contributes to it
and that you know we got to do something
about it where does that fit into
the kind of basket of uh of things that
you're yeah well i've
as as you've you've seen i've i've
commented on this on several
interviews and uh and so for for many
years i've been saying that okay the
temperature's been rising for over a
century
now and human activity has contributed
to it
but the approach is wrong this top-down
approach
which they're using supposedly around
the world
and emissions keep rising so it's not
accomplishing what
what does it what has accomplished and
will accomplish it
are innovations bottom-up innovations
that
for example uh substitute
uh a natural gas for coal
and and so this is what we're working on
at koch industries as i said
we've uh we've invested nearly
uh 30 billion dollars in technology
and and that's led to us
uh let's say our our production of
fossil fuels a decade ago
was maybe around a half of our business
now it's just a fraction
and our emissions are are less
across the board in our plants and we're
we're
working on inventing things that will
do two things not just have less
emissions but will be cheaper
and more affordable rather than much
more expensive
and unreliable which makes people's
lives worse so our
we go back to our basic we we're
committed
to making people's lives better to and
succeed through
mutual benefits so we've we've developed
a
system to automate uh the detection
of of emissions from plants
of releases and and that greatly reduces
the number
and magnitude of releases we've we've
developed a superior
5g connection
system communication system for electric
cars
we've invested in a company that that
has electric vehicles for delivery yards
where the whole thing is automated and
we're not only invested in we're using
this
in our in our our our plants
uh and then we've invested in a
a new small scale
modular nuclear plant technology
that i mean that's a huge could make a
huge difference
and it's safer and cheaper if it
once again doesn't get over regulated so
it makes it impossible
and so on and i i could go on and on
these are the
things we're doing because we believe
that's that's that's the future and that
that's the only way
we can deal with whatever these problems
are going to be in the future
from temperature rising is through
bottom-up innovations you know
you mentioned regulation and donald
trump uh who
uh you know in in his four years in
office and
likely his only four years in office he
uh came in talking about deregulating
things
and most of the business people i know
that i've talked to have said that there
was a palpable difference
during the trump years than under the
obama years for instance and that
regulations seem to lessen even if you
don't necessarily see it
in the number of pages in the federal
register and things like that
how do you guys feel and not just about
business but like
was donald trump good for the country
and then
also what are you looking forward to
what's good about biden and what what
worries you about as we move into a new
political era well nick my my sense is
that
that's what a lot of people are asking
in the country right now
but like we write in the book right
there is so much more to life than
politics
that if we if we ask too much of
politicians whoever they are
whatever party we are as a country
likely to be disappointed
and so what we're trying to do is
encourage people to look beyond
sort of that narrow lens of politics
look politics plays an important role
but it's a limited role
then that's by design in our country we
want to find ways that people can come
together outside of
politics government policy i am right
there with you but let me press you
brian i mean was
was trump was it you know was it was it
a good thing that he was president for
four years and kind of burned down
certain types of institutions and when
we look at somebody like joe biden
and i'm thinking you know from a from a
kind of standard libertarian analysis
joe biden promised 11 trillion dollars
in new spending he's not going to be
able to deliver on that but like does
that make you look forward to the future
or
does it make it harder to get outside of
politics did trump actually make
it harder to get outside of politics
because we all talked about him every
minute of every day
i'll put it this way i think that there
are a lot of ideas that are being
offered
to solve some very real problems in our
country right i mean the division in our
country is real i think it's a
reflection of deeper
challenges that we talk about in the
book the core institutions
not empowering people to keep up with
the pace of change
and and different flavors of top down
can appeal
because they seem almost like magic
wands
but what we try to do in the book is
show as history does
that it's a lot tougher than that right
that the really the only way to overcome
some of these problems is not to take
you know whatever it is
the flavor of the of the top down of the
day but really do the hard work
to help to build an inclusive society
that empowers everybody
and so that's i mean that's that's what
we're focused on that's what we think
the
the future can hold and and look
politicians are going to play an
important role in that because
government policy creates the conditions
for these
other institutions to be productive but
ultimately the majority of energy needs
to be
outside of government outside of
government policy in the voluntary
sector right i mean i mean this is this
is reason this is what
what what we've dedicated our our
careers this this is a
a good way to pivot to the libertarian
movement and charles you know more
more than any uh individual uh and and
certainly with you and and
your brother uh you created envisioned
funded uh the libertarian movement as we
know it
i believe the oldest institution that
you are consider you know continuously
involved with was the institute for
humane studies
uh most of the operations that you're
talking about are in this voluntary
sector
could you talk about what um what drew
you to something like
ihs and you know how has that played out
and how does that kind of
um reflect your vision of what
uh libertarian philanthropy and a
libertarian society should look like
well what uh what drew me to the the
institute
was that uh as i said
that these ideas transformed my life and
enabled me
to accomplish more than i ever dreamed
and and so i wanted to help as many
other people as possible be exposed to
these ideas so
they could help them do the same and
that's what the institute was working on
and i guess just for people who don't
know the institute for humane studies
funds seminars scholarships
uh academics for college
students as well as professors young
faculty people who are
involved in having a life of the mind
yeah and that's the same thing
with the mercado center does does uh
similar things
in a somewhat different methodology and
that's what attracted me and that's
where
i met brian when he first came to work
out there
out of college so those are the kind of
institutions i was
i was interested in and but but we were
uh the the the people who believed in
these bottom-up ideas
it was mainly talking about the theory
and the history how it worked through
history and i said we
we've got to deal with show how it can
deal with real problems
and so that's that's why i helped start
the cato institute
to take these abstractions and apply
them to real
issues and and then
i said well we've also got to
[Music]
show that these ideas really work to
change people's lives
so we've got to go find people
professors
uh people in communities i i provided
the seed capital for the institute for
justice to start
i started an organization in the 70s
called well we initially named it blast
business leaders against subsidies and
tariffs and i got milton friedman to
to work with me to become the the
chairman of
of advisors and
and the idea was to get business people
to
to see that they're better off not going
for short-term
profits rigging the system and really
creating
value for others and you know a typical
letter i got back
i mean nobody would have answered me but
because milton was there they said god i
love what you and milton are doing i
totally agree with but it doesn't apply
to my industry
for example one made jeans and he said
he said gosh because if we're put out of
business
by my foreign competition who's going to
make the boys genes in times of war
and so oh my god so anyway so we changed
it to citizens first sound economy
uh and because
citizens citizens were the ones who were
getting screwed by this
uh and the business people were making
money short term because long term
they're destroying society with this
but that's just a minor point i guess
what you did and uh from things that
i've read and you know
just talking with people one of the
things that you did charles was you
kind of envisioned a series of parallel
institutions
um you know if if libertarian thought
was certainly not represented
it wasn't even represented in the
republican party really in the 60s very
much
much less in the media much less in
academia much less in kind of business
roundtables
i mean do you feel like you succeeded in
helping to create a
kind of sources of parallel information
and
um and kind of community building or
mission building
um you know well i feel this when
for example when we were first i first
got involved in instant humane studies
we would be lucky
to get six professors in the country to
come
to participate in a seminar now
depending on how you count them there
are thousands of professors
who are doing it so and so that's in
that
and then and then what we've done my
wife and i 30 years ago started an
organization called youth entrepreneurs
in one school in a in a tough area
to help these kids find their gift
and so it's not just classroom what what
i call one dimensional schooling teach
to test top down
everybody treated the same but tailored
for each individual
and and it blew me away that these kids
who were failing everything started
making straight a's
and they were transformed and then
called went on to be successful
and now it's in over 20 states and we
have sponsors in all these states that
are
they're helping it work so so it was so
i look at all those
things we did in all the institutions
and how it's
uh it's helped and now
now we we work with people across the
whole ideological spectrum and all the
institutions
now how do we get it to its critical
mass
and it reaches everybody and that's what
we're you ask what we're doing to the
future
we've got to scale this and we've got to
get the message out a lot better
and that's what we hope believing people
will help do
yeah brian that's uh you know i've been
a reason for
27 years i believe i know you've been
involved in uh
ihs mercatus et cetera for 20 years what
20 years 20 years yeah
and you know we can certainly say that
in that past time our
reach our visibility i think our
influence has gotten bigger but it's
you know it's not where i think anybody
in the libertarian movement would like
it to be
you know and um so what what are the
deficiencies
in the existing kind of uh you know
structures or organizations or mindsets
and where do you see it going because as
the head of cki
you're going to be in a position where
you can real you're going to be making a
lot of bets on what's going to play in
the future
so could you talk about that yeah look i
i'll
i'll give you two answers right and i
think they're complimentary um
one i think is a mechanical answer right
we we need to do a better job
of the mechanics of sharing the
opportunities for people to get engaged
in really empowering people from the
bottom up right i mean that that's
ultimately what we're talking about
helping people to find how they can live
their best lives by contributing the
lives of others that's that's the
liberal project
and and from a mechanical perspective
organizations that have been dedicated
to that mission
we've been pretty clunky and we're
getting better i think you know i mean
these 27 years 20 years we've seen a lot
of improvement over time
we've got a ways to go there we can talk
about that if you're interested i think
there's some pretty basic stuff
that can be done to dramatically improve
the effectiveness what
what what's one quick example practice
what we preach right this division of
labor by comparative advantage for a
long time you remember this right there
were these
organizations that were kind of silos
right each one of our
groups well we we were the one that were
going to save the world right we could
we could solve it all on our own
and we'd see each other at events and
parties cocktail parties that sort of
thing and we
we talked to each other we wouldn't
really work together and that's changing
quite a lot and i think that's a really
positive sign and it just
interject then back in the early days
there was a lot of divisiveness
and people not speaking to each other i
mean it was unbelievable
i mean gosh we gotta work together but
but the more
the more fundamental answer nick i think
and this is the thing that i i think
you know what reason's doing right now
and some other groups i think is really
really productive on this front
we got to take up hayek's challenge
right we got to once again make the
building of a free society an
intellectual adventure or as he says a
deed of courage
if there's ever time for courage for
those of us who believe
that that liberalism and empowering
people
to find new and better ways to
contribute in society if there was ever
a time for us to sort of stand up with
courage and advocate
for that i mean now is the time and so
if we can bring that spirit
into our efforts and as charles says put
together put aside some of these petty
divisions
and welcome more and more people who are
out there looking for a better way
into this liberal project right this
this this charge that hayek has has
given us for generations
i i mean i think we ought to be we ought
to expect to see a whole lot
more uh progress and you know look let's
not lament where we are
you know don boudreau is a somebody who
always reminds me
hey we got our problems and we do but
time horizon matters
and so if you look say from the 60s
until today
and you just consider the number of
people in the world that are living
under more liberal
conditions however you want to measure
that
i mean it's a tremendous success of
these ideas and i think we got to keep
that perspective in mind as well
well the other the other insight of
hayek's is is to
to make progress you can't continue to
use the language that worked decades ago
you've got to find where people are
particularly young people
and what language appeals to them and
put it in those terms so
you we have to go where people are and
show them these ideas in ways they will
relate to
and that's what we're that's what we're
trying to do and people say well that
isn't
the way we used to talk about it well no
we've got to innovate
we've got to do things differently you
know if they don't want to hear
praxeology they can go to hell
yeah we're going to you know well i was
going to name my
my first book the epistemology of
praxeology
it was pointed out that would only
appeal to you
you know russ roberts another guy that
that that's familiar to your your
uh crowd is um i used to work with him
at the mercado center for a long time
he would say you know russ wrote novels
right that was his idea to try to get
more people engaged in ideas
he would say to me look ryan as much as
we'd like them to
nobody's sitting around campfires
singing songs about praxeology
right but today i mean we've got the
opportunity
you know the examples in the book people
like scott strode people like anton
lucky people like um like the other
social entrepreneurs
they are literally sitting around
singing songs about the work that
they're doing i mean these are the the
heroes of liberalism going forward
and then we get musicians together and
they're singing songs
and they're oh my god and they tell
their stories
about how they overcame it and then they
have a song about it oh
right boy it brings tears to your eyes i
guess this is a good time to invoke bob
dylan
who shows up very early in the book and
uh you know
arguably one of the most controversial
claims in your book
is that you say that bob dylan
absolutely deserved the 2016 nobel prize
for literature
i heartily agree um charles you you
quote
uh from uh it's all right mom only
bleeding uh early on in the book uh he
not busy
being born is busy dying expand on that
a little bit how does how does that
summarize a lot of what we're talking
about
i mean bob dylan is like me he's
he's uh he's totally committed
and obsessed with his gift
and he has a gift for understanding the
human condition
and putting that in a way that people
relate to
through his songs so he's
he has a tremendous gift i understand
that
if he's having a party and a song starts
to come
he leaves the party and goes down to his
his studio and writes the song while
it's with him
and that's he reminds me of me
[Laughter]
i wish i could write a song but no he
has
uh he's constantly reinvented himself as
well
yeah no absolutely that's it continual
transformation
and and he is amazing i have his
whole book of songs which i i refer to
and i there's so many that have great
powerful messages in them that yeah it's
just
it's very inspiring you think of dylan
never picked up an electric guitar
right because he kind of he stayed
within the bounds of what was
and look he was a very successful folk
musician at the time
but he broke those barriers and i mean
imagine the music that we wouldn't have
today if he hadn't done that
right brian do you you're also a dillon
fan uh what is
what's your favorite dylan song if you
haven't it's an impossible question to
answer right but i'll give you one and i
won't explain why
it's uh blood on the tracks it's called
idiot wind
sure and i'm gonna i'm gonna stop
talking at that okay that's uh
yeah it's a wonder we can even feed
ourselves you got it you got it
my mind is just mine is forever young
yes all right and oh and there's two
versions of that on the same album so
that's uh
you can pick it is being born uh as a
final question uh
charles you you
and and your brother um who was a
longtime trustee on uh reasons board of
trustees
you guys were among the most hated
people
in america you know for many years you
may still well be
uh you know and kind of the way that
george soros had became this icon of
hatred and contempt for people on the
right jezza
what did it what does it feel like to be
you know the subject of that kind of
attention well i'd
like i i i'm a big fan of karl popper's
scientific method which
is develop a a testable proposition
and then go find what's wrong with it
and get other people to criticize it
and why do i do that and that's the way
we run our business
because my my little ego
is strong enough to handle the criticism
but it isn't
strong enough to handle the massive
failures that come
by not getting better knowledge and i
don't know why
everybody doesn't have that rather than
protect their you know i don't want
i know all the answers shut up do what i
say
and then have disasters and so i
i look at the criticism i mean some is
constructive
and and then okay we need to learn from
that and then i need
then learn okay why why are these people
doing it
or do they want to shut us down and then
okay how do we how do we deal with that
so each of these attacks
is i find very educational
so i want to learn from them and
learn where they're coming from how we
deal with that because
i want to be successful and unless you
can deal with criticism
and overcome it uh you're
you're never going to be successful like
like john
stuart mill says those who only know
their side of the case
know little of that well
we're going to leave it there thank you
very much uh brian hooks
of the charles koch institute and of
stand together charles koch of koch
industries
the book is believe in people bottom up
solutions for a top-down world
gentlemen thanks so much for talking to
reason today thank you thank you
great interview
you